Hunter Biden was all smiles last night
the first son hobnobbing with the
Washington Elite at his dad's White
House State dinner just two days after
that sweetheart deal but his troubles
are far from over Republicans releasing
damning testimony given by two IRS
whistleblowers they claimed that the
president's son received preferential
treatment during the Department's
investigation but what's got everyone
talking is the bombshell WhatsApp
message they gave the committee the one
that implicates Joe Biden the 2017 text
has Hunter Biden invoking his father's
name while pressuring a Chinese business
associate connected to the Chinese
Communist party for payment quote I am
sitting here with my father and we would
like to understand why the commitment
made has not been fulfilled I will make
certain that between the man sitting
next to me and every person he knows and
my ability to forever hold a grudge that
you will regret not following my
direction
the text completely blowing up Joe
Biden's consistent claims he's never
been involved in his son's business
dealings
Mr Vice President how many times have
you ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I've never
spoken to my son about his overseas
Louisiana
yes yes yes God love you man you you're
a one horse opponent
Hunter's lawyers not denying that the
first son actually sent the text message
quote any verifiable words or actions of
my client in the midst of a horrible
addiction are solely a Zone and have no
connection to anyone in his family and
as usual the White House is stonewalling
like crazy
just not going to comment from here
I will what I can tell you is I know
that my colleague has dealt with this he
addressed this at the White House
Council I just don't have anything else
to share I just answered the question
yes or no was the president involved
Stephen Stephen I just answered the
question I just said I just this is it's
not up to you how I answer the question
I just answered the question by telling
you my colleagues at the White House
Council has dealt with this and I would
refer you to them
Joe Biden's attorney general responding
to the whistleblowers claims and denying
that there was any interference
Mr Weiss Who was appointed by President
Trump as the U.S attorney in Delaware
and assigned this matter during the
previous administration would be
permitted to continue his investigation
and to make a decision to prosecute
any way in which he wanted to and in any
District in which he wanted
okay well there you have it so on the
one hand we've got Hunter Biden's lawyer
not denying that the White House or that
the what's app message was sent
threatening that guy connected to the
Chinese Communist party uh company that
they were negotiating with
um and yet Joe lying and continuing to
say he knows nothing about his son's
business that's kind of who do you
believe Joe or Hunter someone goes down
and it will be Hunter first the only
question is will it stop it Hunter Joe
Biden is going to have to make a
statement he's going to have to say that
my crackhead son was making things up
that is literally going to have to be
what he says my son who's addicted to
drugs was making things up about our
relationship and our ability or an
attempt to influence China in a pay for
play bribery scheme or Joe Biden has to
say Hunter's telling the truth it's one
or the other and the levels of
corruption are so fascinating as they
begin to unfold judge by by the way at
the most shallow level we know now that
Hunter Biden was not paying taxes while
his dad goes out there and says hey
billionaires have to start paying their
taxes but that's literally the most
shallow level what we find out of course
is the media is corrupt this
intelligence agencies are corrupt the
doj is corrupt the final card to fall in
this house of cards is when we
acknowledge with evidence and we are
close that Joe Biden is corrupt it's
either Joe Biden or Hunter is a
crackhead who's making up lies
okay so then we've got on the other hand
we've got Merrick Garland Kennedy saying
that you know David Weiss Who was
appointed by Donald Trump had all the
authority he needed to indict and do
whatever he wanted in the investigation
except now that we have whistleblowers
telling us that the ausa on the case
working for David Weiss her name is um
Leslie Wolfe said she didn't want to ask
about the big guy uh and that she was
told not to ask about the big guy so we
have another dichotomy here David Weiss
has not yet spoken Merrick Garland says
I will give him permission to speak and
uh it it appears that the prosecutors
are saying they couldn't even go near
the big guy investigation so it makes
you wonder who were they working through
who were the proxies that were
delivering this information to the
assistant U.S attorney on the case
because you know it seems if you've got
this direct evidence leaking linking
rather the president to some pretty
nefarious activities wouldn't you want
to investigate that and they wanted to
ask some Hunters associate Associates
directly about the connections between
Joe Biden and some of these deals that
were going on and they weren't allowed
to do that and you know they do it in a
way that gives them so much cover that
will never really be able to get to the
truth because those conversations
probably happened verbally I can't
imagine there's a lot of text messages
after you know Lisa Page and Peter
strzok that leave betrayal from you know
someone in the Attorney General's office
to the assistant U.S attorney but
obviously something has happened here
and we deserve to know what it is so I
don't care if it's a Republican or
Democrat it doesn't happen in successive
administrations but also like we always
wonder like how did Hunter get this
money and now like he's being a big fake
tough guy and and he's threatening
people using the power of his father's
connections right and just just a little
primer here uh David Weiss wanted to be
special counsel okay he didn't want to
stay just the United States Attorney
because everyone knows here and in the
Department of Justice that you do not
get an indictment especially against a
high-level person unless it is approved
by the attorney general and I bet my
house on that so let's go back to uh yet
another dichotomy where we've got these
two whistleblowers one is a high-level
career IRS agent the other uh and this
individual has spent years in the
criminal investigations and then we've
got a second whistleblower and neither
of them has a political ax to grind they
talk about Rob Walker the guy who set up
the llc's saying that Joe Biden actually
made an appearance at a meeting with
Hunter and that walker uh and the others
set up the deal with the Chinese energy
conglomerate cefc and then we we've got
Bob olinski who has already told us that
a Navy Lieutenant retired that Joe Biden
came into another meeting with Hunter
and the Chinese and specifically that
there was money a percentage put aside
for the big guy was held quote
separately with the association hidden
who do you believe there
big if true the same thing that you have
to say about all of this I mean James
Comer and Chuck Grassley Jim Jordan
Nancy Mays have all gone on TV and
talked about things like this and it's a
very intricate story but I I can't
follow all of it I I don't know all the
names as well as you do but I know that
they haven't been able to produce the
goods yet we were promised tapes a week
and a half ago
no well I'm not asking about the tapes
I'm asking you about the whistle but I'm
giving you a complete answer that will
involve the whistleblowers I just want
to say for the record that the informant
that Rudy Giuliani talked about missing
Giuliani had to recant on that Chuck
Grassley more highly respected than the
rest of them talked about tables so
we're going back
a lot worse so okay so let's get to Gary
shapley one of your whistleblowers the
career guy there are three core claims
that he made about what went on that
have already been refuted first and
foremost he said that Garland lied to
Congress saying that white had total
Authority I just told you we did
himself told Jim Jordan on June 7th that
that was not true and that he did have
complete authority to say that he wants
to keep his job at this point
which was to deliver no good could you
just let me get through it and then you
can keep going the second point about
this he alleged shapley that Weiss asked
to be a special counsel what jury talked
about and Garland has refuted that if
you want to just say that everybody in
Christendom is a liar that's one thing
but I'm going to trust the Attorney
General especially one who testified
under oath third point
shapley alleges that there was political
interference and that Weiss was denied
the right to charge Hunter Biden in DC
now the DC U.S attorney got in touch
went to the Washington Post last night
and he said that's absolutely not true
that he could have been charged anywhere
so there was no political interference
whatsoever I've maintained from the
beginning that if all of what you say is
true and they're you know like Bugattis
that I will believe you if the facts are
shown to me and I can actually see it
and there are direct lines between all
of this that has not been done yet and
this whistleblower having three core
components to their testimony about what
happened being refuted already they're
not refuted they are they're not refused
what if 50 of it is true
aren't the whistleblowers if they're
found to be lying can't they be
prosecuted I mean they're risking their
freedom for these statements so I think
you got to put some weight on that but
let's let's keep it real this is the
Teflon Sun you know he's he's he's
guilty on all things and you always have
that out where like will said well he's
a crackhead so he used his dad name for
influence but I always look you have to
go back at patterns let's go a little
bit further back there is a reason why
with the great success that the Obama
Administration was having that Joe Biden
didn't just fall in and run there's a
reason there was a reason they jumped
over him to go to Hillary and it was
reasons like this his sloppy work his
inconsistency there's always been a
cloud of stuff around him whether he's
lying about his background he's lying
about his accomplishments there's always
been stuff about bribery and whatever so
for whatever reason he was not chosen
when clearly his entire career has been
he wants to be president now they use
the thing he was mourning Beau that
doesn't hold water anymore there's a
reason why the Democrats said no the
pandemic had an opportunity and I don't
think anyone thought he was going to run
and now he's running and all those
things they tried to put to bed before
are here now so we can wait to see how
it is but if it walks like a duck and it
quacks like a duck I'm calling it a duck
let's have some foie gras shall we oh
that's cruel it really is well lemon
juice and raisins we'll have the fake
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else